well I'm very glad you asked that
question we just did three sets dinner
with what would happen if we did four
okay now you want to make sure this is
big enough okay no common sense would
dictate look - looks like this three
looks like this if you want four add
another circle okay let's give this a go
show I'm gonna draw it like this take
take you to the one step at a time okay
hold on I have to concentrate okay now
you have to be careful with it let me
give you a tip the way to make sure you
draw it reasonably accurately is when
you told these ones that you draw their
overlap okay
the overlap between these two about that
intersection write it try and make it
roughly the same size as this
intersection down feel if you make it to
like different you make one bigger one
small it'll throw your diagram now you
won't be nice and symmetrical okay so
what do we think of this diagram mine's
not bad it's not perfect let's preview
it but it has a problem it has a problem
I wonder if anyone can work out what the
problem with that diagram is let me just
not label it I should say you know you
got the universal set out there too many
colors
Universal set I'll call this one a call
this one B call this one C call that one
D okay now just for the sake of it you
know for instance one of the pose before
when you were throwing different kinds
of Caro diagrams at me I'll come to the
second member one of the problems I said
was wedg where would you prefer where
would you put it that was my question
now clearly in he'll see that that's the
overlap I'll just wait until you ready
picks out a diagram shall we right in
the middle right smack bang in the
middle
I do have an overlap an intersection
between eight feet see empty but there's
a problem
come on I think you had your hand up
first and then we're gonna bring them
yeah multiple regions that follow the
same path
what do you mean yeah can you give me
example okay so this is an India yep so
I hear ya also this would be a and B and
C so I want I want an A and B and C yeah
I do want that
okay so honk
Brent Brennan can you explain since Tom
mention it brenneke what do you mean
keep point out to it the case so let me
try to replay out in case you didn't
catch that let's think about ways to get
a and C and have a look at that overlap
it's in here here here and here you see
that keep here you are but there's a
problem
all of these areas right in all these
earrings
you're either in B or Y or indeed you
can never be in a and C but but not
those guys right so in here I need to
have four sections but I only got three
and you can you can replay it doing it
this way right now just in case you're
not convinced by that you know
hocus-pocus
okay there's an easy way how many
sections were this year there were eight
I'm gonna put the numbers on here um 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
there are eight sections how many
sections would you expect should be over
here now
I heard 16 now that's that's an
interesting idea
you're gonna need to draw this 16 is a
very good guess but why is it a good
guess it's so important okay all right
I'm gonna walk us all through it
cuz I need to go in about 15 minutes
so I'll make sure we get here please
draw this you don't need to draw it
nearly as big but draw it underneath
wherever you've drawn your for second
okay um we jumped straight to three sets
and now we're taking on four okay one of
the greatest ways you can see identify
with is these inter inconsistencies is
by taking it back take it back do
something simple for instance let's do
zero sense
now you're like zero sense it's a bit
boring okay well just wait and see
here's zero sets you know and as the
universal set and there's no substance
no substance
how many regions are there there's one
region and the region it is is well it's
it's there's nothing in it it's the
empty set is what we call all right
that was zero let's add on a set shall
we sir here we go small one okay there's
the universal set out there and then you
add in a so now how many regions are
there are two firstly there's no sense
right and then there's one set a okay
so here's one he's the other one okay
let's go to the case we're more familiar
with two
okay so here we go one two the universal
set a and B okay how many regions are
there we already know there are four but
be more specific about the four what are
the four there's well how many ways are
there to have no sense it's just the one
the same one we've had yeah there is a
single way to get no sense how many ways
are there to get just one set there are
two ways to get one set you can either
have a or you can have be okay and then
because now I've got two sets I can say
well how many ways are there to get two
sets and the answer is there's one way
for way forward okay so now when we got
to this case here okay let's go a b c
okay now we counted I counted one two
three four five six seven eight
but what are the eight because they're
not all the same and this gets to where
my order is okay what was the first
thing I picked out
it was the universal set how many ways
there are to pick no sense and it's only
one way how them any way is to pick no
sense that way and that's it how many
ways are there to pick three sets sorry
once it once it lets get three sets no
there's um there's this way and this way
and this way two three four you see you
see where I've gone I've got a I've got
B and I've got C okay
how many ways are there to pick two
sense
five six seven
can you see those regions I've picked
out they're the ones which have two sets
only okay namely you can have a and B or
you can have a and C or you can have
when I missing B and C okay
let me see one more here right how many
ways are there to pick 360 and of course
there's only one right namely may be see
so you count him up and you get eight
these numbers are suspicious to me not
just that we get one and then two and
then four and then eight so now you have
very very good reason to expect that
there will be 16 next this that was a
very suspicious to me let me try and
write out why these numbers are
suspicious what 1 1 3 3 1 I guess what
I'm expecting next is there's going to
be it should be on this diagram one way
to pick no sense the universal set the
empty center there should be 4 ways to
pick one set of course there should be
because I want I have four sets
how many ways will there be to pick two
sets
there are ways six ways how many ways to
pick three sets there will be four ways
you can write him out how many ways will
there be to pick all four sets there
will be just that last region in the
middle and that my friends looks like it
adds up to 16 okay so what do we got
here
this this is not the Venn diagram that
we want it's not the Venn diagram though
in fact there is that there's a proof
for this the reason why it doesn't work
is because we have circles believe it or
not circles on the problem hate them we
need to abandon circles circles as it
turns out are too symmetrical it's their
symmetry that leads to this problem so I
need a shape that's not quite as
symmetrical will still do the job so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna show
you a few different studies I'm gonna do
it like this I have to really
concentrate to get this right okay now
it's not as beautiful because it's hard
to draw okay but we can check very
easily if we got it right can't we have
a look how do you redesign it I count
one over here I'm gonna count to three
four five over there okay let's see how
it going I'm gonna go six seven eight
yes so far so good
12 13 14 15
oh snap there we go so like I said it's
not as people because it's it's harder
to draw but of course if you know what
you're doing or you've got the help of
something which you can draw perfect
shapes for you then this doesn't
actually look all about it bad come back
to this guy okay this was our three cent
Venn diagram
okay our troubled three-step Venn
diagram actually there is a way to
modify this and it's not that bad to get
a fourth set onto here okay the only
problem with it is
I don't think very beautiful but what is
that it's not going to be a circle in
fact in this arrangement what you're
gonna get is you're gonna get that's
fine it's kind of a smiley face clown
face sausage type thing okay but you can
count it up you get your 16 regions